what can you say about the
other characteristics of these objects
like shape
size
texture
luminosity
how else do you describe object is there
something that could be said so you said
like this detect down radar step one now
you have clear images that can give you
a sense that it's actually a physical
object what else can be said about those
physical objects so eventually someone
did see one with their own eyeballs
multiple people
and it and they saw it in a kind
somewhat interesting way
the object presented itself at
the exact altitude and geographic
location of the entry points into our
working areas
so we enter at a very specific point at
a certain altitude and people leave the
areas at the same point at a lower
altitude
probably one of the busiest pieces of
sky on the eastern seaboard
so two jets from my squadron went out
and they went flying and they entered
the area where these objects went right
between the aircraft so they're flying
in formation and the object went between
the aircraft they went between the
object i think i don't think that the
object was moving i don't think it
aggressively went at them i think it was
located still there and then they flew
through it
but they didn't have it on their radar
um
and that would
i think the radar might have been
malfunctioning i don't know that for
sure i would like to look into it but
my supposition is that if their radar
was malfunctioning it would make sense
that they wouldn't avoid the object that
was there because they knew these were
physical at that point
um and we we would go up to these
objects all the time time and try to see
them we couldn't see them and we didn't
know what it was um was it that were
they just not there were being fooled
was something happening were they were
they moving dropping out to the last
minute you know we're going by pretty
quick so it's difficult to tell
um but perhaps if his radar wasn't
working he wasn't receiving energy from
the jet
and the jet of course didn't know that
it was there and so it whatever the case
was they flew right by and they
described it just as a dark gray or
black cube
um inside a clear translucent sphere and
the kind of the apex of the cube were
touching the inside of that sphere
that's an image that's haunting so what
do they think it is what did they think
at that moment uh that they is it just
this kind of cloud of uncertainty that
that they're just describing a geometric
object
it's not on radar so it's unclear what
it is
um yeah what was
uh the
any kind of other description they've
had of it in terms of
the intuition from a pilot's perspective
you know you have to kind of identify
what a thing is
to answer the first part they they
actually canceled the flight and came
back because they were you know it's
like if there's one of these out here
we're almost hitting them and it's right
there then um you know perhaps we need
to get a different jet with better radar
but so they came back and they're in
their gear and they're they're talking
to the front desk and talking to skipper
and like hey we almost hit one of those
damn things out there and this kind of
was one of those
kind of slight watershed moments where
we all were kind of like all right like
this is a serious deal now yeah you know
maybe it was a maybe we thought they
were
balloons or drones or malfunctions or
maybe we thought it was spying but the
end of the day if we're gonna hit one of
these things then we need to you know we
need to take care of the situation
and that's actually when we start
submitting hazard reports or hazard reps
to the naval through the naval aviation
safety
um
kind of communication networks and it's
you know it's not like a big proactive
thing where people can go investigate
it's more of a data collection mechanism
so that you can kind of share that
aggregate data and make sure things are
progressing
so it wasn't a mechanism that would
result in action being taken but we were
hoping to at least get the message out
to whomever was maybe running a
classified program that we were not
aware of or something like that that hey
like you could kill somebody here like
you've you've grown too big for your
britches here take a step back
so that was that was our concern at that
point that's kind of where we were
thinking this was going
you